[Music]
December 2018
the US military detect a huge explosion
in the Earth's atmosphere high over the
Bering Sea off the coast of Alaska when
an explosion of this magnitude is
detected everyone's mind goes to the
same thing nukes but when the real
answer was found and it was determined
that it didn't even originate from Earth
that was even more shocking the cause of
the blast and asteroid
this asteroid was 30 feet across
something like that over a thousand tons
but it was moving at 20 miles per second
over 70,000 miles an hour this asteroid
was small and it exploded in the
atmosphere over the ocean so nobody was
hurt but if it had been bigger or I'd
had come in over a different place or it
had been moving a lot faster this could
have been a dangerous object but the
scariest thing about it is that we
didn't see it coming
so far we've been lucky
but near-misses happen all the time
about once a year we get something the
equivalent of nuclear bomb going off in
our atmosphere and while that sounds
horrible
most of these happen in tens of miles up
over open ocean where we go on
completely oblivious we may be oblivious
to most of the threats from space but
they are very real we're going to get
hit over a certain amount of time an
asteroid impact is inevitable it will
happen
100% absolute certainty
[Music]
NASA considers the threat from the skies
so severe it has made protection from
asteroids a top priority these events
are not rare they happen and of course
it's up to us to make sure that we are
detecting and characterizing tracking
all of the near-earth objects that
potentially could be a threat this is
not about Hollywood it's not about
movies this is about ultimately
protecting the only planet we know right
now to host life and that is the planet
Earth to help plan protecting our home
we carry out earth defense simulations
for three days 200 scientists at the
planetary defense conference battle a
simulated asteroid 20 times larger than
the bering sea's space rock we practice
alright what if this hits a major city
what would we need to do by running
potential impact scenarios we can
prepare for a real asteroid strike this
is like a fire drill that you would do
at school or at work where you practice
and think about okay what if where are
the exits how do I get out how fast do I
get out
the drill starts with the discovery of a
simulated Earthbound asteroid so the
first information is there's a big
asteroid coming towards the Earth then
we get a better estimate of how big it
is how fast it's going and where it's
going to hit the asteroid is heading
straight for Earth with Denver Colorado
in its sights the planetary defense
scientists send up a simulated
spacecraft to smash into the asteroid
and push it off its path but it's a big
gamble you can push it the wrong way you
can potentially have unintended
consequences in the simulation the
spacecraft strikes the asteroid
deflecting it away from Earth but the
impact dislodges a 200-foot chunk which
is now heading straight towards the
eastern seaboard so there's this one
last piece that is now going to hit New
York we know that something that size is
going to have citywide consequences that
is huge that's a horrible impact
when you're actually in the conference
room and you understand eventually that
New York City is going to be destroyed
and you're having strategies about how
to evacuate people all the timing when
you're doing the simulation you're in
your head you're thinking about these
things you're trying to reason them out
but can you imagine the feeling in your
gut right in your heart if this was real
if this were real the chunk of asteroid
would strike Earth's atmosphere at
43,000 miles an hour as the space rock
hurtles down it collides with molecules
in the atmosphere which Buffett the
falling rock it's kind of like doing a
belly flop into a pool right you're
going from the vacuum of space into the
dense lower atmosphere in in mere
seconds and that's an incredible amount
of pressure to put on the object the
asteroid slams into the air ahead of it
compressing it violently the surface of
the asteroid gets hotter and brighter so
actually the air itself that's glowing
luminously
from the heating of the shock wave the
world's most intense sonic boom if you
will that heats the air to incandescence
as though as the object passes through
so that's the source of that brilliant
illumination this bright burning
asteroid is called a bolide
we witnessed one descending over the
Russian city of Chelyabinsk in 2013 all
of a sudden there was a huge fireball
streaking through the sky and people had
no idea what they were witnessing
because it looked like the sky was on
fire it was insanity as the asteroid
descends the compression of the denser
air beneath it starts to flatten and
even disrupt the falling rock there's a
high pressure on the front there's no
pressure on the back and it's being
superheated in that intense temperature
causes the air to glow which is how we
see the streak of the meteor and it also
disintegrates the asteroid self it's hot
enough to literally melt rock this can
often lead to them exploding
the combination of heat and pressure
invade the falling asteroid causing it
to blow up
most asteroids don't reach the ground
before they completely disintegrate in a
tremendous release of energy this is
what we call an air burst and we learned
a lot about these while we were testing
nuclear weapons after World War two
some of these bombs were blown up
underground and on the ground but they
found out when they blow up bombs above
the ground it actually did more damage
it was more widespread damage the
explosion of the Chelyabinsk asteroid
sent out a powerful shockwave at
thousands of miles an hour
the blast traveled over a hundred miles
it damaged 7,000 buildings and put 1,500
people in the hospital all of the
injuries pretty much came from people
who saw oh what's that bright flash in
the sky and they came close to a window
to look and see what it was and then the
pressure wave hit and blue glass in
their face the Chelyabinsk asteroid was
only 65 feet across the rock in the
defense simulation is three times more
massive and it's heading straight for
New York City
imagine what would happen if an
explosion a thousand times greater than
that over Hiroshima hit New York we're
talking about an utter complete
destruction of the city and millions of
people with so little warning the only
option would be to evacuate New York
City how do we get everybody out of New
York City within just a few days that's
where panic sets in
that's where fear would really become
the dominant emotion anyone left in New
York City would see the bolide racing in
[Applause]
followed by a blinding light as the
asteroid explodes above the city
the blast would be equivalent to the
largest nuclear weapon ever detonated on
earth buildings would be flattened
melted there would be fires for miles
around in the first moments of the
explosion a million people could be
killed instantly and many more would die
later in the rubble in the ruins of what
would happen there everything within
nine miles of the blast epicentre would
be completely destroyed the intense heat
and pressure would wreck buildings it's
the worst possible day for New Yorkers
and not just the city itself there's
something like 15 million people living
in the New York area the shock wave
would race out over 250 square miles
this would certainly be the worst
disaster that the US has ever
experienced we're talking about millions
and millions of people displaced
affected within an incident
this scenario is just a simulation for
now
the asteroid Apophis is heading our way
if it hits Earth it might not just kill
a city it could kill a whole region I
wouldn't exactly want to be there when
that happens one be very very far away
Apophis will skim earth in 2029 but its
path could change possibly turning a
future miss into a direct hit